yeah I think humor can transcend
political differences although a lot of
times people if it's a political joke
people from that are the target of the
joke tend to be a little more sensitive
however done right i think i think that
done right humor can make people that
are even the target of a joke laugh a
lot of times people want you to talk
about them so if you call a spade a
spade they are almost they almost have
to laugh and if they don't laugh then
then it kind of reiterates the joke so
when you have a Democrat make in front
of a Republican hopefully the Republican
is willing to laugh and vice versa the
difficulties as a satirist coming from
the Middle Eastern I grew up in America
so I'm very Americanized I would say
that you know within my own community
sometimes there's people that that don't
have the sense of humor that you would
hope that they would sometimes that's a
cultural thing I think that sometimes
people that come from the Middle East
where respect is a big thing you're not
supposed to make fun of certain things
and certain people but in America you're
supposed to go after everybody so I
think sometimes that creates a little
bit of a problem when you have people
from your own background they get
offended at certain jokes and I think
that in America the Americans that maybe
sometimes I would say the Americans that
that that see my shows sometimes a shock
that the fact that there's actually
humor in our culture's a lot of times
Americans don't even know that people
from that part of the world have a sense
of humor so it's not so much a problem
as it is them having to discover you and
go oh wow there's people from that part
of the world that actually are funny
what I see the future politics I'm
hoping that with as the as the internet
brings more and more people into the
conversation that the that that people
are more open minded with things it's
almost like I'm just having this
conversation with somebody else right
now it feels like definitely America is
becoming more and more diverse and I
think that it's hard for people to try
and maintain an old-school conservative
mentality on anything whether it's
people's sexuality or race immigration a
lot of these things so I think that I
hope I'm very hopeful that the future is
a promising one and I'm hoping that no
matter what party it is they got to
start accepting that it's a diverse
world and and and that there's some some
light at the end of the tunnel with with
all the with the politics today women
and politics are going to be taken over
look at a kickass women are women are
smart women are I mean it's that's a
that's a silly statement but it's true i
mean we all know that that there's a lot
of smart women a lot a lot of great
female leaders and when i see some
countries that that that don't include
women in their politics or in their in
their day-to-day it blows my mind and I
don't know what they're thinking and I
and I do think that uh that women in
this country or have a very bright
future first female president is coming
up soon yeah